might talk on the table I'm very excited
to welcome award-winning actor James
Roland who is right here in studio
Brolin of course has been called a true
renaissance man he has started numerous
TV shows and films including Marcus
Welby MD and Catch Me If You Can now
Brolin narrates the Netflix series Sweet
Tooth it's based on the DC comic book
series of the same name about a viral
pandemic that leads to the mysterious
creation of babies born part human and
part animal in this clip from season two
Gus a hybrid Dear Boy helps a doctor
trying to find a cure for the virus
well Gus got to walk in the footsteps of
the woman who brought him into this
world
Dr Singh got one step closer to finding
the answers he so desperately craved
thank you guys
you helped me a great deal today
you hurt Peter I'm never helping you
again
foreign
first on CBS morning's James Brolin
joins us now James thank you very much
for being here
um oh my gosh you know we do we do we
have to track our pieces that's a word
for it but it just means voice over like
you're doing in this and yeah I am
embarrassed by how good you are you are
amazing your voice is so cute yeah over
the years have you all done
um demonstration tapes for your age yeah
getting 40 of them over the years never
got anything really yeah 40. yeah this
is this was the first well so this one
came to be because Robert Downey Jr uh
was an executive producer on the series
uh pitched you on it how did it happen
he's a neighbor right yeah she's a
neighbor and I've recently had lunch
with him and Susan his wife and then I
got a call uh you're who we want for
ourselves well who do I what do I do
it's all up to Warners make your deal
with them that's we're not making any
other decision that's it even read the
script we're going to be doing still
haven't
they trusted me with the voice yes but
they didn't trust me not to Yap about
what the story was I was still to this
day then you set it don't do the voice
over yourself in your home how does that
work well that was during the pandemic
yes you know and uh they weren't letting
anybody on the lot there for a while so
for the first five or six shows they
would deliver
a case like this with a tripod with legs
this big and I'd have to Lug it in set
it up and here is this big ball I opened
it up and there's a big screen an
annoyman mic and headphones and I'm
plugged into the Warner Brothers sound
Department right with the director in
New Zealand directing me wow wow now so
this uh show is the aftermath of a
fictional viral pandemic yeah and um
there are a lot of parallels I remember
2009 though which is pretty wild yeah
and as we were crawling our way out of
uh covid-19 yeah you know there are
these parallels do you see parallels in
what's going on today in this show of
course yeah yeah and you know that's
somewhat of an exaggeration I would
assume that like we've had Millions die
and they must have had Millions die
right but the the kids the hybrid kids
they seem to be blaming it on and we
have situations where the blame went
everywhere during the pandemic here you
know it's interesting you're called a
renaissance man as Tony as Tony said in
the intro I did not know all this time
that you were a pilot that you fly your
own plane I did not know this about you
I got my first my dad was a an engineer
for Douglas aircraft but I never went in
an airplane and one day I got an
invitation to take a lesson at 18 out of
Santa Monica Airport and I was 18.
that's many years ago I've I've had I've
been flying ever since so do you and
Barbara fly around together she won't
get in there with me well I went in
there wants to have dinner with me we
had little Bento boxes and we just sat
there and had dinner she wouldn't let me
start it up well is she a nervous flyer
too very very nervous liar yeah can you
believe that you guys have been married
for 25 years honestly I cannot
how old am I
what's the key to longevity in a
marriage I gotta ask negotiation there
you go that's spot on it and you know I
I had a friend say I'm getting married I
said oh great when soon and knowing six
months after we go to a uh a marriage
counselor for six months as long as
he'll sit there and I think that's it
you know usually either the one or the
other of them said we've had two
sessions and I'm fine yes and I'm out of
here you know not out of the marriage
but I'm not going to see that guy again
I don't like what he said to me yeah
yeah he's on this side yeah part of it
is but you and Barbara had a very
interesting first how you met I think
that this is such a great story yeah
that you that you knew she was the one
because what did she say to you well we
were invited to a party to meet a party
of 30 people it was a gorgeous night
over the Bel Air Hotel on a patio and
she disappeared for a while after
shaking hands with me when she went and
went down and saw the person's kids for
a while and then came on everybody was
seated to dinner and she walked around
me you know 29 people were seated in one
empty place she went to her and she said
who upped your head who screwed up your
hair she used a real harsh word
and uh you said oh man you know I'm here
with a bunch of Hollywood liars and one
person telling the truth there it is
yeah yeah so I I was smitten from that
moment on like a truth teller two hours
of talking nobody got a word in and here
we are 25 years later 25 years later
seven years seven years later yeah you
uh you once calculated that you have
spent in the days of your life more than
9 500 Days on set that's what the kids
figured out that's what the kids figure
out yeah yeah that's a long time I know
getting up at 4 30 in the morning never
miss a day from illness it started with
Stage frightening you said you still
have stage fright still so not but not I
mean on stage yeah on stage that's what
I mean yeah yeah you're fine
here I was in a play in junior high and
the night it opened I left before the
play
somebody else held the spear
and actually the first person that ever
came up to me about working on film I
said well I wouldn't have to talk would
I matter of fact not you just drive this
Dodge truck and now the Cowboys now
you're still talking I was like it I was
a leader in elementary school play and
then they heard me sing and they made
the chorus everybody together changed
the course of history that's why you're
here and that's why I'm here still doing
voice over I've been terrible at it
thank you very much
yeah you're terrific at it oh my God
what I wouldn't give for that Voice
season two of Sweet Tooth premieres
tomorrow on Netflix